[Music]
instead times news submitted by I love
bacon and eggs keep eggs
you guys like thin crispy or thick all
of it bacon my God's love is beyond the
edges the one from Causton pie is my
favorite bacon Oh their bacon I like all
of them
you like the rubbery one yeah Julie one
what why both it's like eating leather
it's good in a sandwich Krispies good
with just eggs a woman over fire this
conversation I'm not having the
conversation I'm doing this I'm turning
myself into a silent ninja a woman
opened fire at YouTube headquarters
wounding three people before taking her
own life
I remember this has just happened I
found out on Twitter about it
Twitter's like so huge huge huge because
she couldn't get subscribers or what
you're about to find out you're even up
to guess her Lois oh yeah oh you could
tell me if I'm right
fact-checking um I could be fakeness
what I read on Twitter was that her
YouTube had taken away her ads but she
only had 12 subscribers or she got
demonetized she got to monetize yes and
then so she went there to like oh oh I
thought see you famous
I let me tell the photos 5,000
subscribers is like having 12
subscribers right yeah I guess in the
world of Adsense yeah yeah an Adsense
job on the 12 subscribers though yeah
zero yeah that's enough not to knock it
but I'm saying like money-wise she
wasn't making millions of dollars to
want to go kill people
Zack Lee that's [ __ ] up yeah so this
chicken and the theme of um 39 I know
usually we don't like to give give a lot
of attention to people that do these
things but this is just a particular
case like 20 year old yeah I thought
that would be like a 12 year old or
something
but like I'm not here that would happen
she's in the middle of a story
Tiffani you get here that's crazy oh
sorry
okay let me do a reset for you okay this
way go ahead alright so usually we don't
like talking about shooters or like give
them much attention cuz [ __ ] them right
but this is just a such a weird case so
this woman here so first of all it's a
woman shooter like that's not super
common Oh was an animal rights activist
she's a vegan bodybuilder of course you
mean a terrorist what do you mean of
course that doesn't make any sense
I'm just saying stupid [ __ ] jail come on
now look at my face oh my bed but a lot
of animal rights activists that are also
like vegan they're crazy they're pretty
militant what are you all the people
that built that blow-up a lab full of
humans because they're doing their
testing lab mice yeah i'ma kill it's not
fair to say imma kill 200 you have your
Malcolm X's then you have your [ __ ]
Martin Luther King's alright so there's
just different left in the animal right
activists extremists oh you didn't add
the extremists you were just like was
assumed no it's not I'm gonna show you
guys a video and they explain a lot and
you can also see some clips from her
channel she was really what what is she
uh
so she identifies herself as Persian she
speaks she's Iranian Farsi and but she
she lived in San Diego she has the
longest neck on earth she came to Mary
[ __ ] good eye she she's buried here she
was born in Iran she's been in the US
I'm from 96 1999
ready it looks like I hear that on
YouTube this is a recent video posted by
Nasim Adam in it she complains that
YouTube has started filtering her page
adding age restrictions to keep her
viewership down family members in
Menifee where she used to live tell us
she had been making a living as a social
media personality posting an English
Farsi and Turkish about animal rights
and becoming a vegan but also making
more upbeat music and dance videos
last weekend when they couldn't reach
oceans by phone or at her home in San
Diego they alerted police and at Chilean
Thursday morning they got word that Adam
had been found safe in her car in
Mountain View California when the family
realized that was close to YouTube
headquarters in San Bruno they told
police that Adam had been complaining
about YouTube and how the company was
quote ruining her life they say police
told them they would keep an eye on her
why does she look like she was sent from
1980 I know it's like Freddie Mercury
and Michael Jackson the white one had a
baby yeah is crazy yes she had about
five thousand or more than five thousand
she's probably below not now I think
they deleted her channel or something
like so she was so these are all her
channels so first like they went after
like her Farsi Channel and then their
Turkish one and then yeah like she was
just complaining on how YouTube was
filtering her out so here she says
YouTube dictatorship hidden policy
promotes stupidity discriminations
suppression say no no good a suppression
of truth and then her website how about
her video sucked and no one wanted to
click it I think maybe she really truly
thought they were being they were
discriminating against her because she
was like okay first they went after this
channel now they're going after my
Turkish channel and then she just felt
like she was being censored yeah and
really be shut her channels down that's
what she claimed yeah like one after the
other yeah and then he or she says like
she was emailing YouTube about
discrimination she says that but they
ended up responding about a account
activation and like I don't know she's
she's saying all these things too and
like she's putting dates on how many
views she would get but then she would
only like for thirty thousand views
who'd get ten cents and then she also
talked about this other video like a
workout video of hers where they
age-restricted her video even though
there's nothing wrong with it but she
was just saying like they're just
discriminating against me that they want
to keep people like very chic minded and
like it's only what they want we all
have our qualms with YouTube though
right like nothing but like for
whether we have zero subscribers or 100
million like that I don't I personally
don't think it's any reason to go off
and [ __ ] soul she's a little crazy
cuz most of those decisions that are
being made are from robots yeah not from
human beings algorithm ever yeah yeah
and so like a lot of us are getting hurt
by it like yeah for sure
yeah I can't breathe but you would never
go someplace with the intention to hurt
someone else just because you you're
blaming them for something that's out of
their control they're just they're doing
their job
yeah I'm shooting three people with her
own legally purchased and registered
9-millimeter Smith & Wesson handgun
before taking her own life Wow the
victims are a 36 year old man that's
still in serious condition a 32 year old
woman and a 27 year old woman who have
since been discharged from the hospital
it was a fourth person that suffered an
ankle injury while fleeing so she didn't
get shot okay that person is not worth
mentioning but she shot somebody in that
one why would they report that ankle
injury no because they were just
reporting how many people got injured
yeah but that doesn't count as the
injury but someone that got scared like
when she came in - suddenly people cut
it away that he was sick he busted a
Ferguson oh yeah it was yeah because I
thought he got shot in the oshi's she
said she laid it out there
she shot three people maybe that's why
the fourth one threw me off I'll say
wait what happened and then she was like
be twisted their ankle I was like don't
[ __ ] write that reporters like what
the [ __ ] I just want to say all the
injuries that happen they did they were
saying four people were injured three
gunshot was the crowd that would make
sense
mm-hmm because they originally thought
that it was a lover's quarrel exactly so
that's what I thought too
first they were saying that it was
probably a domestic incident because of
the velm
male victim yeah but then later they
said that there was no evidence that the
shooter knew the victims or that the
individuals were specifically targeted
and so they're all the police is also
saying that there
is no link between terrorism so they
don't believe it horses not sure she's a
weirdo but it's crazy like cuz a lot of
people are so mad at YouTube but I don't
think they'll be this mad they're really
mad at YouTube there's a lot of people
that are pissed at YouTube right now a
lot like a lot of people got hurt over
the years we got lucky yeah we got
really really lucky like our channels
you know we're kind of under the radar
cuz we're not too popular but there's
whole entire channels that got
demonetised
yeah and through the years gets sifted
out you know it's like they can't even
get views at and anymore yep yeah I
don't know it kind of seems like that
was happening to her but she felt that
it was because of what she was talking
about her new channel and the fact that
like she speaks Farsi and Turkish and
all this other stuff well she could be
watching other people seeing it
happening and thinking that it's
happening her to her channel as well I
don't know but you can't really logic
with crazy crazy is just gonna come up
with every reason in the world just like
it was a personality or is like a fake
personality or issues I really like that
yes it was pretty creative though like
it's odd for sure it's odd but because
she's kind of crazy it looks pretty cool
it looks like aa video just kidding baby
yeah I was very mean screaming
everything no be like when she's like
talking about YouTube just remaining her
like just the way she speaks about it
it's like she's really passionate about
it yeah like her being targeted for sure
and then like the family knew and that's
why the family told police like hey I
think she might be targeting YouTube
they didn't know that she owned a gun
though oh but the family knew she was
crazy like yo my daughter I can't save
her [ __ ] [ __ ] man you guys gotta get her
if I had a crazy-ass daughter I would I
would have told them the truth
I don't trust her look I did my best man
[ __ ] she chose that oh I don't know what
to do like police you gotta do it man
who are you reporting to the the police
station real quick paper clip did sook
Allah is about me
my sweet [ __ ] Paperclip he's just
weird he's that's the name they came up
with not me
do you like it so the police are also
saying that she visited a gun range that
morning of the shooting so she was
trying to get her last minute practice
at that's horrible that's vodka yeah but
it's it's so different cause it doesn't
even fit the profile and the narrative
is just so different right like like a
woman vegan you know like animal
activist didn't mean anything but then
like yeah that's all right
animal activist to be okay with killing
people because aren't you supposed to be
pro-life everything right a lot of
animal activists rather kill people than
animal yeah because we're the ones
torturing the animals yeah we're not
torturing then we're eating them yeah
right I don't know how do you guys feel
about this no cuz it kind of hits close
to home since we're it's kind of scary
cuz you never think that like anything
in my new media or social media would
ever get targeted like this so when I
first heard about I was like oh [ __ ]
this is like really close to home I just
feel bad for all the YouTube people is
just like they're just hey Bob
go get some sushi for lunch oh yeah and
then they just come in like oh [ __ ] you
don't expect that at YouTube you know
like that's just one of those things
where I don't know it's so weird
maybe up their [ __ ] security
dude yeah we better get that [ __ ] tight
they never seem to work yeah they're
saying that it seems that she you may
have gained entry through the courtyard
area which is easier to access campus so
even like I'm pretty sure they're gonna
I mean she's just really weird-looking
like if I'm security I'll be like you
gotta back the [ __ ] up you look weird
you do space la you can't get in there
possible without someone buzzing you in
like you just can't walk in there like
exactly cuz that's that's why you can't
just walk in and look at her dude she
looks like a llama
[ __ ] it don't weird yeah she looks like
a long from 1980 yeah yeah million girl
get away from my youtube channel Hey
yuck man you know what people are too
accepting
that's the issue people should
discriminate more yeah where to all
inclusive hell yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you're too [ __ ] ugly get out and get
out of my office man you're gonna do
something [ __ ] up I know you are just
on your [ __ ] eyebrow [ __ ] like I I
swear to god you're gonna [ __ ] start
shooting me trust your instincts
you know what ear and all that [ __ ]
we're built that we're built that way
like the biological way for a reason
it's to tell us when you see that
[ __ ] poisonous frog with all those
colors that's a danger zone you know so
when you see a ugly-ass [ __ ] that
looked like she just came from 1980
looking like a llama and she's wearing
those clothes you say [ __ ] no get the
[ __ ] back right now just like the way
she looks you gonna tell her how she
walks
you know you mean like it's just very
late there's no soul behind those eyes
in every video it's just the totality I
don't know man if you ain't got
personality [ __ ] that mm-hmm
[Music]